Hello Freak bitches.
Yeah,
I know a lot of cops,
man,
they,
they see the,
one of the problems is you're a cop.
You see a lot of shit.
I see a lot of shit all the time and you lose your patience.
You lose,
you lose your patients and you,
you know,
you,
you become more attuned to the kinds of the world then you would like to be and
you don't want to hear any fucking bullshit anymore.
So very,
very fucking tricky job.
My,
my pain.
Your humanity.
My question is this,
now you're always seeing the worst in people being did I know that there are
people out there who really do risk their lives.
Like if someone's house is getting robbed or,
well,
how about this guy?
The fucking,
this guy in Denver,
man,
they had it.
Someone had to go in there and stop him.
You know,
this isn't,
this isn't something that you,
you know,
the community can just rally together.
No one had guns.
But my question is the,
the police that break the law,
should they be held more accountable because they know the law that much better?
Like in other words,
if you had killed somebody to ever or should you get time
minimize?
For example,
there's a case in in New York where a guy,
he got like a a year of probation or something or was it a year in one year in
jail is because he killed a guy while he was drunk driving and he's,
he's his family is apparently connected with the NYP ds.
This is my question though.
If if you're a caption should be held accountable to the law even more so
because you knew it was wrong to be drunk and driving.
You arrested people probably a hundred times for doing the same thing.
You don't think that it's ever been shown that to put people in a situation
where it's whatever they're doing that's wrong has more of a consequence.
I don't think that's ever been shown to them.
It have any effect on their actions.
I think people do shit cause they think they're going to get away with it.
They don't do shit because they measure the consequences and go,
all right,
I might do a year in jail.
Fuck it,
let's ride.
They don't do it like that there.
It's,
it's more of an impulsive sort of a thing when,
when people make mistakes,
but if people know,
listen,
there's no way that I'm really going to catch it that much heat for this because
who the fuck is,
right?
If I'm drunk and somebody pulls me over and we both play for the same team,
you're going to bring me in.
Do you know what's going to happen in you after that?
What's really crazy is how many cops turned out to be corrupt back in the days
before the Internet.
I mean,
I think it's very difficult to be corrupt today,
but I think back in the day it was probably pretty fucking easy.
I miss,
I think it's slightly less difficult to be corrupt.
I mean,
I think you can if,
if there's money in it for you,
you know,
and I think there's levels of corruption,
there's harmful levels,
and then there's simple stuff like,
you know what?
I'll fix it.
Tickets for you.
You know,
we're good friends.
That's corruption.
Whether or not it's,
it's bad.
Those kids are dying.
Someone shouldn't have the ability to do that and they say,
you know what,
you're connected with me.
I'll give you the card when you have a problem,
you call me and I'd take care of it.
I know people that benefit from that.
I know people that had been in situations where they may not be 100% right and
they have a specific card or something like that and I'm not denigrating thing.
I'm just saying that at some point,
you know,
are you more responsible for your corruption because you know the law 10 times
better and you're enforcing it and forcing it.
In other words,
if you get caught for murder and then you're off all of a sudden in five years,
that's only because you knew the law better and then you still broke it.
Well,
he was selling drugs to pick.
I said,
I don't think that you can,
you make people more responsive when you going to change.
Thank you.
Might make people feel better because you're punishing them more,
but I don't think you're necessarily going to change behavior by offering a
bigger consequence.
I think the only way to change behaviors to change thinking,
and what I try to tell people is it sounds ridiculous,
but this is something that came to me on a boat once,
is that you got to treat everybody as if it's you living in another life.
We could all do that.
If we could all picture ev,
any person,
regardless of what the fuck they're going through in your life,
think about what it would be like to live that person's life from birth to death
with their situation,
their economic situation,
their biological situation there,
their life experiences.
Would you be any different than that person?
If you were that man,
if you were that woman,
would you be any different?
Are you them?
You know,
if that person was born you,
would they be you?
And Are we all the same like that?
And is that what life really is all about is figuring out that each one of us is
exactly the same.
We're just living through at different biological circumstance.
And the more you can treat everyone you meet,
like there,
you living another life,
the happier you'll be.
And that's the only way we're ever going to sort this thing out is everyone has
to do things based on that ideal everyone had,
whether it's business or personal shit.
Whatever you do,
you always have to think that this person that you're dealing with is you living
another life and you can't let them boss you around.
Can't let them talk shit to you.
Can't let them fuck up your life.
You know you do your best to keep them on track,
but your ethic and your resolve and your,
your intent should always be to treat them as if it was you living a whole
nother life.
Okay.